- A viewer wrote in via email,
should they do jury duty?
I think this is a great question.
And the answer to that
is unequivocally, yes.
Number one, not only is it your civic duty
to make sure that the
government doesn't overreach
and that you protect everyone's rights,
which in turn protects
everyone one else's rights,
but it's also an incredibly
fascinating experience.
Every time I've done jury
duty, I am lucky to be there.
And here's one secret that
you might actually not know
about jury duty, which is
that in many jurisdictions,
the judge is given a list
of the jurors who gets paid
for their time on jury duty.
And often judges bend over backwards
to make sure that people
who aren't compensated
for their time on the jury are not
selected because that can be a
huge hardship for the jurors.
But if you are compensated for
your time by your employer,
then you're more likely
to be on jury duty,
and of course it makes it more likely
that you can fulfill your duties.
So in answer to your question, yes,
you should do jury duty.
So I'll see you in court.